this is like the true story of five
pulls picked to live in a hole and have
their lives taped
to if I know what happens when you stop
taking out the trash and start acting
like pieces it's the Bangalore Falco and
moogle are bored sure they love each
other kinda come to think of it they
really haven't even consummated this
marriage so let's put a little spark in
this relationship even better how about
three sparks it's baby-making time the
21st century way I don't need
intercourse doctor give me three hits of
Falco three germs of mughal a-- three
petri dishes and let darwin do the rest
excellent numero uno the oldest daughter
we get less personality traits the
younger they get but thank God we know
the essentials they're dirty mean
definitely obscene they're the unwanted
clam meat far Glee next up let's change
it up instead of Public Enemy
it'll be a smart conniving brat and even
though I should pick slob for this one
personality slot it's time to tap into
the traits evil his name is Karl or Karl
irken up everyone and he will people
pets furniture all just have to spend a
little more time with this guy and make
sure he doesn't shower or do any dishes
and lastly there's Gary who starts smart
but is burdened with that family gene
slob hmm Carlo and Gary can't both be
whiz kids
let's change Carl or to a playful
rambunctious scamp with no shoes this
family is complete mom dad meet your new
kids oh what a happy family but enough
of this meet and greet you kids have
your first day of school tomorrow time
to get some rest
damn forgot about beds again well that's
fine we'll buy some double damn we only
have $748 time to sell but nothing
extreme golden cows can go some
flamingos some house lights but that is
it
the Bangalore's got an image to keep in
this neighborhood in
I ain't gonna let these needy kids and
their beds take that away which is why
this family needs to make some
sacrifices new family rule kids sleep
outside and shacks if this family is
gonna bring in any Joe Falco and Mughal
I need this room to let their talents
grow don't worry the girls get a toilet
we're not raising some kind of farm here
Jesus but I don't trust Carl or he needs
some good old-fashioned isolation all
right it's time for bed my children
tomorrow is a new day
well good morning Carl or come on into
the house big guy
Papa's making breakfast
god damn falco who cuts themself three
times
sounds like someone didn't get a lot of
sleep alright let's fast-forward time
for school guys what's this Berkeley
find some money in the bathroom should
she keep it yes obviously
alright school's out how was your first
day at school guys o our lord
embarrassed because he hasn't showered
well don't you turn your back on me get
your ass back here I know just the thing
to cheer you up my little angel there
you go Oh better huh okay so the gang's
all here what should we do tonight well
now that the kids are in the picture
it's the perfect time to invite
ourselves over to the Henderson family
next door for a nice warm welcome Falco
you know the drill
all right we're off to a good start
Lulla greets Wanda with an insult that's
nice Falco and Bobby hitting it off
literally a car Lauren Jack becoming
besties well look at that father like
sauna
looks like Lula is complaining about her
marriage typical Gary's freaking out
about some smelly shoe oh boy
lugal has no shame flirting with Bobby
right in front of Falco where's his wife
oh boy busted okay time to go everyone
Carla needs his nap and so does mama
well for the first family outing that
went horribly but hey that's the
Bangalore way right the Bangalore house
slowly falls apart Falco and Lou glogg
get dolled up and go out clubbing bar
Glee babysits but when she's too busy
texting she lets car lures sneak off to
the park at night where he meets a
homeless man in the public bathroom
the bangalore yeah
you